hey guys it's angelico with max tech and
i've been using the galaxy z flip 4 for
about a week now and i want to talk
about my experience with using a flip
phone for the first time both the
positives and the negatives and if i can
see myself buying one of these in the
future first i want to start with the
design and how different using this
thing is compared to my iphone
as far as quality it is amazing it's so
solid it feels great in the hand it's
gorgeous and unlike the iphone its frame
does not collect fingerprints at all
which makes it look really clean now the
main aspect of this phone is of course
that it can be folded and compact
carrying it in my pockets it's
definitely thick and not the most
comfortable phone to have in your jeans
however for guys that have more loose
pockets the flip is actually more
comfortable to carry in your front
pockets because it does not jam into
your body like bigger phones do along
with that in looser clothes like
sweatpants my iphone would fall out of
my pocket every time i get in and out of
my car but the flip did not it stayed in
every time which was really nice now i
wasn't expecting the hinge to be as
sturdy and high quality as it is
this thing stays in literally any
position you want without budging but
the downside with that is that it's
really hard to get open with one hand
which really bothered me day to day as
in order to use it you had to get it
open first which is a feat along with
that i don't have the biggest hands and
this phone is pretty big it's a lot
taller than my iphone which makes it
really hard to use with one hand for one
the volume buttons are almost all the
way at the top of the frame which is
extremely annoying i wish they were
lower where the 5g antenna or
fingerprint sensor is speaking of the
sensor i hate that it's built into the
power button and i wish i had an under
display scanner instead that would make
it a lot more convenient to use because
of that i've been using the facial
recognition option instead even though
it's not as secure as apple's face id
now onto the display i wasn't sure how
i'd feel about the crease but after
using it i actually love it it's
extremely subtle and doesn't bother me
in the slightest when scrolling through
text you can't see it at all it's
seamless however a little thing that
annoys me is the way that the screen
protector has this cut out for the front
camera
it's really distracting and it sticks
out like a sore thumb compared to the
quality of the rest of the phone in my
hands on comparison when i looked at the
brightness the flip was dramatically
dimmer than the iphone then i went and
saw that there is an extra brightness
toggle and after turning that on the
brightness reached about the same level
as the iphone this is something that
really bothers me about samsung why do i
have to go into the settings and turn on
all of these things just for the phone
to perform at the same level that an
iphone does out of the box the quality
of the display itself is amazing i have
zero complaints and it's so nice to
finally not have that horrid iphone
notch in the way the flip also has a 120
hertz display which is one of my
favorite features of all time
and with that it also has an always-on
display option that you can turn on
however that feature kind of goes to
waste because of the flip design and as
far as the speakers they are just as
good as the iphone 13 pro so
no compromises there
um
[Music]
now this phone has a usbc port which is
great for all the people that wish the
iphones had usb-c and are sick of
lighting being able to charge all your
devices without having to bring a bunch
of different cables everywhere is really
nice however for me personally it didn't
really make a difference because i
always use wireless charging and with
that i love how the cover display shows
your battery percentage while you're
charging so you can easily see when
you've charged it enough however one big
thing that i really missed having was
magsafe i always knew that magsafe was
one of my favorite unique features of
the iphone but not having it for a week
this phone really made me realize how
much i cannot live without it i use
magsafe every single day at work and
being able to see all of my
notifications and use my phone while
it's floating and charging right in
front of me is really nice it also means
that i always go home every day with a
full battery and at home if it ever gets
low i just throw it on my belkin three
in one that i love and i can still do
whatever i need while using it like
watching movies i also recently started
using this moft wallet and stand just to
pop up my phone and watching stuff and
it's so convenient that i don't think i
can ever go back and now let's talk
about the cameras and i'm honestly not
super impressed with them max vidimi and
i just did a blind camera comparison
with this flip the iphone 13 and the
pixel 6a
and the less expensive iphone 13 beat it
out by lot and the flip even lost by one
point to the super cheap budget pixel
phone not only that but it costs a
thousand dollars the same price as the
iphone 13 pro
which has an extra telephoto camera and
a lighter sensor which gives you really
good portrait photos so if the regular
iphone 13 beats it out then my 13 pro is
way ahead now one benefit with the flip
is that when it's closed you can use the
main camera on the back for selfies
resulting in much better quality images
honestly i don't really care too much
about it and i can't see myself using it
but if you can see yourself using it
then it'll definitely come in handy for
you so would i actually switch and use
this phone permanently
honestly no at first i was super excited
about the flip i thought it was the
coolest thing ever and then i would
absolutely love it but after actually
using it my mind has completely changed
about the biggest feature of this phone
that it folds using it day-to-day the
flip aspect of it hindered my experience
more than the benefits it provided it's
really hard to open with one hand and
while using it it's so long that i
literally cannot use it comfortably
without using both of my hands along
with that i don't carry around a purse
so i always keep my phone in my pocket
and this thing is just so thick that i
would rather just have an iphone that
sticks out and after being so excited
about the flip aspect
to me i've realized that it's kind of
more like a gimmick the z fold 4 makes a
lot more sense to me now because you get
this massive display that you cannot get
anywhere else but the flip left me
disappointed now that is not to say that
this is a bad phone at all and i'm not
trying to tell you that you will not
enjoy it
but i've just come to the conclusion
that it's not for me if you're out there
wanting to buy a flip phone or have used
one in the past and liked it then you
are definitely gonna love the z flip 4.
the quality is outstanding the display
speakers are incredible the crease is
super subtle and if you have big pockets
it's going to be super comfortable to
carry and just overall i think this
phone will have great longevity and
it'll look new and modern for years to
come so thank you for watching if you
guys like the channel click the button
above to subscribe and check out one of
those two videos over there this has
been angelica the editor with max tech
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you